I don't know why they didn't say who
they was when they came through the door
that night because they would never
happen like he did
despite 100 years of heavy social and
financial costs and no indication that
victory is attainable the US government
continues to wage its war on drugs this
is the story of Cory Mae and Ron Jones
two of the countless casualties of the
war on drugs I'm the mother of seven
children five boys and two girls and
core vista baby corner was a shack he
yet when he was growing up and I think
he pretty much had his shyness for me
because I have to get to know ya we're
before I mean you're a lot with you but
he was a easygoing child he was a loving
child I always loved or to live on you
you say something to him he'll say yes
ma'am no ma'am but mostly he was very
wrong
quite calling all he did was smile but
he'd never been in any trouble he'd
never had a ticket or anything until
this came
and you ask him do something you didn't
have to ask him twice how you were done
and I liked him Cory may is the father
of two children Cory jr. and to Coriana
he was the babysitter he was a cook and
he was trying to plant - Cory and I had
just like we could but he did the best
he could she went oh mama baby she was a
flat-out daddy baby she just loved being
around him call he had us fall when it
came to those key is he loved loved
those kids and he stared
calm down oh no find the phone but I
still wanna obey Oh burn a whole zombie
Oh
there is a duplex in Prentiss Cory was
living in his side of the duplex with
his girlfriend Chantal and they had 18
month-old daughter to Coriana Cory came
back and said that he might be moving
back to the house because he can't live
over there with all that traffic going
on like that they store day and night
day at night and he said you can't
hardly sleep people knocking on the door
won't say who they are Jeff in Davis
County it's a lot of crime rounding a
lot of drugs and you never know who's
gonna come to ours at night so late that
night I was in here and we were sleeping
I heard somebody banging Melissa opened
the door to find her granddaughter to
Coriana in the arms of Cory's neighbor
they say Cora had shot something I say
Cora I said Cora what are he doing
shooting somebody just like that he said
no they bust in there and start shooting
and that's what he did I got on the
phone right then and I called his mom I
say may I speak to die Melissa called me
and that's when she told me that I
needed to come to Prentiss as soon as
possible and I asked I said well what
what's happened
she said it's been a shooting and so
that's all I could hear so I jumped up
grabbed some clothes and we hit it -
Prentiss Corey's testimony was that he
was asleep in the living room had been
watching TV he awoke with a start at the
sound of banging on the door he jumped
up he got his pistol ran to the back
bedroom where his daughter was basically
hunkered down at the end the opposite in
the bed from where she was lying and he
had just gotten there when the door was
kicked in young and some a figure came
in and he fired he being Cory fired
three shots
the bullet that took Ron Jones life hit
him in his sort of his left side
unfortunate about a ninja - right under
his vest Cory May was arrested jailed
and ultimately charged with the murder
of officer Ron Jones that was a real
tragedy losing Ron and the co community
breathes I really hated to see Ron go I
knew a brother his brother sang a lot of
our church he was an actual singer and I
think you were just an excellent family
all together and I wish I had him back
he was very good police officer he was
very caring about every night but he
wanted drugs eradicated in this county
very much so ostensibly they had a CI
confidential informant that had been
there earlier that day been in both
sides of the duplex according to the
testimony and had personally observed
large amounts of cocaine and marijuana
in both sides of the duplex the warrant
itself and I've seen the warrant it had
the name Jamie Smith on it Jamie Smith
at that point in time had drug charges
pending against him in Jeff Davis Kent
he referred to both sides of the of the
duplex neither Cory's name nor chantels
name were on the search warrant their
testimony was that they came to that
front porch of Cory's duplex knocked on
the door announced well no one came to
the door Ron Jones and another officer
went around to the rear there was a door
in the rear of Cory's condominium when
the court in testimony Ron John was
attempted to kick that door open himself
he could not he gave up was going into
the direction back to the front of the
house another officer that was there
went up the steps succeeded in kicking
the door world
but Ron came back ran up the steps into
the condominium the bedroom the
condominium and that's when the shots
were fired he's told me that as soon as
the third shot was fired he heard
someone outside say police or the
equivalent of that which is the first
time he'd ever heard anything as far as
any any language and as soon as he heard
that he quit firing he slid the gun
which is a pistol across to the door
that had just been kicked open and got
down on the floor of the apartment and
of course the officers came in
immediately and Cory tells me that he
told them I'm sorry I didn't know it was
a policeman didn't know it of course
Cory was jailed that night it's been in
jail ever since these are holy sales
down here those box we have to to room
first they they decided to make me
senior because I went over there by four
or five ten me and his father and they
wouldn't ever let us see him and I said
because they didn't want me to see the
bruises that he had on him
205 as a holding cell up on the second
floor and he was secured there
he was transport transported by us and
along the Mississippi highway village to
another location for his safety the
first words out of his mouth when he saw
me he heard me and he said he's a mom he
said I don't know why they didn't say
who they was when they came through the
door that night he's because they would
never happen like you did